brought to you by PlayStation view the
new live TV service now available on
your playstation over 100 channels no
annual contract game the system hey
folks Chris waters here on the show
floor at South by Southwest I'm talking
with Ryan the creator of inverses which
is a game that you have to the layman's
I looks like Ryan decided to give guns
to dice and have them shoot it out would
you say that's accurate Ryan yeah a lot
of people like to say it's go with guns
go with guns go is a game that's complex
and though in versus you know has a you
know this sort of simpler simple black
and white look it gets complex really
quick give us a basics yeah so basically
each team is either on black or white
and when you shoot you change the color
so the board's always shifting around
you because you're like making pads for
you but walls for the other player so
it's constantly about like trapping in
the enemy taking them out it's very like
cat and mouse running around the board
it has a very Bomberman feel in that way
that's sort of you know you're just
trying to position right so that you you
know you blast the other person but you
don't get trapped in and with it yet
that constantly shifting board is a real
mind meddler and you have a bunch of
different board layouts to further mess
with folks yeah there's like twenty
seven vs maps right now and each one has
like a very specific strategy i try to
do and some i really try to screw with
your brain and put like non-euclidean
spaces in there and crazy stuff but like
you're not generally used to looking at
and it's really fun yeah one point we
were playing and I it was just me versus
you but I had I was on the screen twice
in two different places and so alright
which one do i watch but if you're only
watching one then maybe you're not
seeing the thread from the projectile
that's coming from across the map ah but
competitive isn't the only way to play
the game yeah there's also on arcade
mode where you can play single player or
co-op and it's kind of like if you took
say geometry wars at robotron and mix it
with the territory control mechanic and
adverse is so it it's a much more
strategic version of like a dual stick
shooter than you've played before this
is one of those games that really it
captures those feelings of like
intensity and that competitiveness that
franticness but in such a simple ordered
way that it almost like fools my brain
into being like oh yeah I'm gonna be
good at this but then you know we had
some pretty tight matches yeah
it's really just encase like I play it
again and again and again and because
the board changes every match it's like
you can keep replaying it and like you
have that like interest that holds to
get better and better and better and
it's the skill gap is large between
someone starting out and someone who's
played as much as I have and it's which
is awesome because I hope it'll like
really grow online as people keep
playing all right so you got online
multiplayer coming out what sort of
platforms are you targeting here and
what kind of release date for in versus
so it'll probably late summer and on
PlayStation and steam and also be on
humble store probably you know wherever
you can get it on PC fantastic Ryan
thanks so much for talking with us about
inverses man folks keep an eye out on
this game it's intense and this is
definitely one to light up your living
room